[Música]
decenas de videos como este de vehículos
que transportan ilegalmente cigarrillos
combustible y otros productos circulan
en las redes sociales en túnez estos
hombres son los natria que son
contrabandistas tunecinos que juegan al
gato y al ratón con la policía a lo
largo de cientos de kilómetros en
dirección alivia o Argelia los vídeos
publicados en tiktok tienen hashtag y
cuentas dedicadas al contrabando a veces
en código y también generan millones de
visitas fajos de billetes maniobras
persecuciones a gran velocidad estas
imágenes sensacionalistas glorifican la
vida cotidiana de Los Traficantes uno de
ellos accedió a darnos su testimonio de
forma anónima no verán su rostro y
transcribimos sus palabras
Entrar en este mundo es más difícil de
lo que parece no terminé mis estudios un
familiar en el contrabando y me metió en
esto el contrabando me salvó de estar
desempleado tenía que trabajar y ganarme
la vida de lo contrario Cómo podría
mantener a mi familia
cada uno compra o alquila una camioneta
comprarla cuesta 120.000 dinares y
alquilarla a largo plazo 60.000 dinares
el motor puede alcanzar los 180
kilómetros por hora sin esfuerzo y puede
transportar tres o cuatro toneladas de
mercancías nos organizamos en una
caravana de cinco o seis vehículos a
veces hasta 20 en raras ocasiones vamos
solos pero es mucho más arriesgado por
lo general se utiliza un vehículo sin
carga que vigila y va delante del convoy
con el fin de detectar posibles
controles policiales o aduaneros si por
el camino se encuentra con una patrulla
nos avisa por teléfono mensaje de texto
y ajustamos nuestra ruta
[Música]
para despistar a la policía rayamos la
matrícula para hacerla ilegible o le
pegamos un cartón encima
a veces un vehículo se sacrifica por
ejemplo excediendo la velocidad para
llamar la atención de la policía eso
permite que el convoy de vehículos se
disperse
la actividad informal representa el 36%
de la economía tunecina aún en plena
crisis genera un volumen de negocio
equivalente a 1900 millones de euros el
desempleo que afecta a muchos jóvenes
tunecinos y también la escasez reiterada
de productos básicos fomental
contrabando otro factor que favorece el
tráfico es que en Argelia y en Libia que
son dos países productores de petróleo
El combustible es muchísimo más
económico el país se ve afectado
regularmente por la escasez de
combustible Así que podemos tomar el
relevo de las gasolineras El combustible
es una apuesta segura pero su precio
fluctúa a veces puede venderse 55
dinares el bidón a veces a menos cuando
es así cargamos la camioneta con 50 o 60
bidones en lugar de los 20 de diciembre
Pero entonces hay que tener mucho
cuidado saber elegir la ruta y manejar
muy rápido si la aduana encuentra una
gran cantidad de combustible en el
vehículo la confisca junto con el resto
de la mercancía Y pone una multa uno
elige su mercancía en función de sus
necesidades inmediatas un viaje no
alcanza para alimentar a mi familia
durante más de tres días Así que es algo
a la carretera muy a menudo los
traficantes en regularmente son abatidos
durante enfrentamientos con la aduana y
los accidentes de tráfico son frecuentes
desde 2008 al menos 150 personas
relacionadas con este tipo de tráfico
han muerto Víctimas de explosiones de
los vehículos o de los depósitos
ilegales de combustible y a veces se
pincha una llanta por el camino tenemos
un accidente mientras transportamos la
mercancía entonces llamamos a un colega
y pasamos los bidones a su camioneta si
la policía aparece antes de que lleguen
los refuerzos es mejor incendiar el
vehículo con la mercancía para que no
puedan estimarla e irse del lugar
[Música]
este hashtag es una contracción de que
significa sordo en inglés y la red
social china tiktok con este hashtag
personas sordas de todo el mundo
comparten su vida cotidiana e incluso
enseñan algunas frases del lenguaje de
señas frases que todo el mundo debería
conocer hablamos con una de ellas que
publica regularmente vídeos de su hijo
que es no oyente
soy la madre oyente
tiene 3 años tiene implantes cocleares
también utilizamos la lengua de señas
creo que se ha convertido en algo
inspirador para mí no solo por poder
compartir nuestra historia sino para
conectar con otras personas que puedan
estar en esta situación similar y
quieren saber qué esperar de esa
experiencia pero también en la
posibilidad de llegar a personas que no
han recorrido el mismo camino pero que
podrían interactuar con niños con
implantes cocleares o sentir curiosidad
por saber lo que significa ser sordo la
comunidad de no oyentes es diversa Y
esto es lo que los creadores de
contenido intentan mostrar en tiktok por
ejemplo Hay personas con pérdida parcial
de la audición otras que usan audífonos
que amplifican el sonido o también hay
quienes tienen implantes cocleares que
captan las señales Sonoras y las
transmiten directamente a señales
auditivas
uno de mis videos favoritos que hemos
publicado es un vídeo que no tenía tanta
importancia cuando lo publiqué fue
cuando era más pequeño y necesitaba
tener descanso auditivos cuando se
siente muy sobreestimulado tiene que
quitarse los implantes fue uno de
nuestros videos más virales y ahí es
donde todo empezó y donde creció y a la
gente le gusta mucho aprender y
significa mucho para mí como madre los
hashtags
son muy populares ya han alcanzado cerca
de 1800 millones de visitas no dudan en
buscarlo para que ustedes puedan
descubrir muchos más vídeos
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores de France 24 Recuerden que
pueden compartir con nosotros sus
historias sus fotografías y los vídeos a
través de los medios de contacto que
aparecen en sus pantallas nos vemos la
próxima semana hasta entonces